on saturday  at my direction  the united states successfully concluded  an airstrike in kabul afghanistan that  killed the emir of al-qaeda  iman al-zawiri  you know zawiri was a bin laden's leader  he was with him all the whole time he  was his number two man his deputy at the  time the terrorist attack 911.  he was deeply involved in  the planning of 9 11.  one of the most responsible for the  attacks that murdered  2977 people on american soil justice has  been delivered  and this terrorist leader is no more  people around the world no longer need  to fear the vicious and determined  killer  the united states continues to  demonstrate our resolve and our capacity  to defend the american people against  those who seek to do us harm